***
*Titelmusik: "Mission Impossible"*
(Computer-Stimme)
Agent identifiziert.
"Guten Tag, Mr. Pop,
das ist Ihre Mission.
Falls Sie sie übernehmen wollen.
Sollten Sie sich dabei
selbst in die Luft sprengen,
wird die Redaktion jede Kenntnis
von Ihrem Einsatz leugnen.
Viel Glück."
*Titelmusik: "Mission Impossible"*
Die Mission ist nicht schwierig,
sie ist unmöglich.
Wollen wir?
*Knall*
*Sie lachen.*
*Titelmusik: "Mission Impossible"*
What?
Tag zusammen!
Jack Pop hier.
"Mission Impossible"
hat abgefahrene Stunts,
die Tom Cruise
fast alle selber macht.
Und es gibt abgefahrene Gadgets.
Wie explodierende Kaugummis
oder metallfressenden Schaum.
Ist das wirklich Agenten-Hightech?
Kann man das selbst zusammenbasteln?
Um das herauszufinden,
sind wir an die Uni Leipzig gefahren.
Zu meiner Lieblings-Chemikerin.
Und haben den Experimente-YouTuber
schlechthin eingeladen.
Wir haben einen Tag lang rumgesaut.
Mission "Do it yourself" startet ...
... jetzt!
Techi, schön, dass du da bist.
- Ich freue mich ebenfalls.
Wir machen heute
ziemlich geilen Explosions-Kram.
Schauen wir die Szene an?
- Auf jeden Fall.
Ich finde die Shots so geil.
Dieses leicht Schräge.
Das ist so geil.
Ich kann mich gar nicht
an den ganzen Film erinnern.
Deswegen wird das sehr witzig.
Er hat den Kaugummi und packt ihn.
Jetzt zieht er ihn durch Flüssigkeit.
Nice!
Sehr gut.
Völlig überzogen, wie die wegfliegen.
- Ja, klar.
So "Matrix"-mäßig.
Aber kann man
auf jeden Fall zusammenbasteln.
Das ist möglich.
Wir haben schon was vorbereitet.
Lass mich mal den Rechner wegpacken.
Und dann schauen wir mal,
was wir dafür brauchen.
Wir brauchen
erstmal einen Sprengstoff.
Dafür haben wir das hier mitgebracht.
Du kannst es besser aussprechen.
Nickelhydrazin-Nitrat.
Das hat eine wunderschöne,
pastellrosa Färbung.
Das Warnzeichen sollte man beachten.
Denn es handelt sich
um einen Sprengstoff.
Von der schönen Farbe
dürfen wir uns nicht täuschen lassen.
Probieren wir es aus?
- Gerne.
Dann müssen wir uns jetzt
ein Schälchen zusammenfalten.
Toll, dass wir erst basteln
und dann fliegt was in die Luft.
Alles, was jetzt zu viel ist,
wird ein bisschen "bum" machen.
Aber das sollte passen.
Ich habe es noch nie erlebt.
Deshalb wird das
gleich meine Blind Reaction.
Noch zusammenfalten.
Vielleicht irgendwie so.
So.
Das können wir nur machen,
weil wir wissen,
dass es durch mechanische Belastung
nicht aktiviert werden kann.
Sonst könnte ich
meine Finger verlieren.
Das, was wir machen,
ist eine thermische Zündung.
Wir nutzen Eingangshitze,
um die chemische Reaktion auszulösen.
Und zu zünden.
Let's go.
Das könnte echt laut werden.
Ja, ich bin bereit.
Das Warten ist immer das Schlimmste.
- Ja.
*Herzschlag-Geräusch*
*Es knallt.*
Wow!
- Ich sehe Metall-Regen.
Guck mal, es schneit Aluminium.
Sehr gut, Herr Sprengmeister.
- Für die Wissenschaft.
Das ist Komponente 1:
der Sprengstoff.
Aber wir haben ein Problem.
Der hat keinen Brenner da.
Wir brauchen
andere chemische Komponenten,
die diese Reaktion starten,
ohne dass wir Feuer drunter haben.
Dafür haben wir eine 2. Mischung.
Das ist eine Berger-Mischung.
Du hast einen coolen Namen dafür.
Ich kenne es
unter dem Namen Negativ X.
Berger-Mischung
ist aber der bekanntere Begriff.
Negativ X
ist ein geiler Agenten-Name.
Tom Cruise
würde auf jeden Fall Negativ X sagen.
Wir testen das für euch.
In der Berger-Mischung
sind 3 Komponenten drin.
Man muss es immer frisch herstellen.
Es kann sich durch Umwelteinflüsse
mit der Zeit selbst entzünden.
Willst du das machen?
- Voll gern.
Das ist Komponente 2.
Die sorgt für die Hitze,
um den Sprengstoff zu zünden.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch was,
was so viel Hitze erzeugt,
um das zu zünden.
Und wir brauchen
eine Zeitverzögerung.
Es bringt ja nichts,
wenn der Kaugummi
schon in der Hand losgeht.
Das wäre nicht gut.
Deswegen haben wir die 3. Komponente,
die die Zeitverzögerung bringt.
Das machen wir mit ...
Natriumhydroxid.
Wir haben hier ein kleines Gefäß.
Dort kommen Kügelchen
dieses festen Natiumhydroxids rein.
Jetzt können wir Wasser draufmachen.
Dann entsteht
konzentrierte Natronlauge.
Die reagiert mit dem Aluminium.
Das ist
eine stark exotherme Reaktion.
Hier entsteht die Hitze,
die wir brauchen,
um die Berger-Mischung zu zünden.
Die dann reagiert, Hitze entsteht,
um den Sprengstoff zu zünden.
Okay, Wasser drauf.
Päckchen zusammen, hinlegen.
Wir haben so 10, 20, 30, 40 Sekunden,
bis das losgeht.
Die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne
eines TikTok-Zuschauers.
Ich höre es zischen.
- Perfekt.
Das ist eine Zeitverzögerung.
Nice.
Wow!
Geil.
Man sieht,
wie die Lauge das Aluminium wegätzt.
Das löst sich einfach auf.
Das hier liefert uns Energie,
um die Berger-Mischung zu zünden.
Diese liefert Energie,
um den Sprengstoff zu zünden.
Wenn wir alles zusammenpacken,
haben wir hoffentlich eine schöne
"Mission Impossible"-Szene.
Oder zeitverzögerten Sprengstoff.
*laute Explosion*
(Jack) Wie machen wir das?
Kaugummi brauchen wir.
- Exakt.
Den craften wir uns jetzt zusammen.
Natürlich nur mit unserer Variante,
wie es funktionieren könnte.
Wir wollen 2 Seiten haben.
Ich ritze das mal an.
Das ist also die Seite
mit unserer Sprengmischung,
also Berger-Mischung
und dem Sprengstoff.
Machst du es drauf?
- Gerne.
Viel hilft viel.
Das wäre jetzt im Kaugummi
eigentlich integriert.
Du musst erläutern,
was genau du vorhast.
Du willst die Folie drüber falten?
Das Natriumhydroxid
machen wir hier rein.
Ich mache Wasser drauf.
Dann klappen wir es einmal so um
und einmal so um.
Wollen wir?
- Ich bin auf jeden Fall gespannt.
*spannende Musik*
*Es knallt.*
Boah!
- Geil!
*Es knallt.*
Nice!
- Das ist ja mal geil.
I love it.
Sweet.
Schaut euch mal die Überreste an.
*Sie lachen.*
Guck mal hier.
Natürlich hat das weder
einen Menschen weggeschleudert,
noch Aquarium-Wände zerstört.
Aber das war auch nur
unsere Nerd-Variante,
um das Thema zu behandeln:
Ist es möglich,
einen zeitverzögerten
Sprengstoff-Kaugummi zu bauen?
Aber ich finde unsere,
in 10 min zusammengebastelt,
ist doch die beste.
Gucken wir nochmal drauf?
- Ja, gerne.
Viel Gerenne.
*Titelmusik: "Mission Impossible"
Jetzt kommt das Team.
Jetzt kommt der Schaum.
- Aha.
Das sind ein paar Sekunden.
Durch den Szenenwechsel
können wir uns so viel Zeit nehmen,
wie wir der Situation geben wollen.
Oh, krass.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
- Jetzt!
Oh!
- Es macht es spröder.
Dann holen sie ihn raus.
Das müssen wir hinkriegen.
Wir brauchen etwas,
das die Autokarosserie spröde macht.
Oder sie auffrisst.
Das ist ja zum Großteil Blech
oder Alu.
Alu als Metall kann man mit
einem anderen Metall kaputtmachen.
Quecksilber.
- Hm, nee.
*Jack lacht.*
Das ist mir ein bisschen zu giftig.
Es ist sehr giftig.
Hast du eine andere Idee,
was wir nutzen könnten?
Na ja ...
Wie wäre es mit Gallium?
Mein YouTube-Kanal
existiert nur wegen dieses Metalls.
*Er hämmert.*
Damit das Gallium
eine Angriffsfläche hat,
müssen wir das Aluminium befreien
von seiner schützenden Oxid-Schicht.
Da es sofort
mit Luftsauerstoff reagiert.
Aber die ist sehr dünn.
Deshalb reicht es zu schmirgeln
und dann das Metall aufzutragen.
Das hat eine besondere Eigenschaft:
einen sehr niedrigen Schmelzpunkt
von 29,7°C.
Wenn diese Flüssigmetalle,
sei es Gallium oder Quecksilber,
mit einem Metall in Kontakt kommen,
löst das Metall quasi das Metall.
Indem es eine Legierung bildet.
Das würde im Falle von Gallium
dafür sorgen,
dass die Struktur des Aluminiums
bröckeliger werden würde.
Wirklich wie Knäckebrot.
Allerdings würde dieser Effekt
mit Gallium relativ lange dauern.
Was wir gesehen haben, ist:
In diesem Schaum findet
eine Temperatur-Entwicklung statt.
Da könnte man schauen:
Wird dieser Legierungs-Prozess
ebenfalls beschleunigt,
wenn wir das Gallium erhitzen?
Ich würde sagen,
das probieren wir aus.
In der Zwischenzeit
kann ich euch zeigen,
dass so ein Schaum
tatsächlich Hitze entwickeln kann.
Wir haben hier Bauschaum.
Der besteht aus 2 Komponenten:
Desmodur und Desmophen.
Die habe ich in diesen Gläsern drin.
Und ein Thermometer.
Wenn ich beides zusammenpacke
und wir ordentlich umrühren,
dann entsteht so ein Schaum,
wie wir ihn haben wollen.
Und wir sehen, dass die Temperatur
bei diesem Prozess steigt
und wir eine Hitze-Entwicklung haben.
Das ist richtig schöner Schaum,
der hier entsteht.
Huhuhu!
Wow, es sind fast 70°C geworden.
Crazy!
Und bei dir?
Es gibt schon Effekte.
Das Gallium
hat sich tatsächlich durchgefressen.
Das Gallium hat gewonnen.
Man kann hier unten
sogar einen Zapfen sehen.
Das spricht weder für das Gallium,
noch für das Aluminium.
Sondern dafür,
dass es sich legiert hat.
Sonst würde es nicht so aussehen.
Ob das Metall
auch spröde geworden ist,
probieren wir ebenfalls aus.
Damit wir es wie im Film machen,
hauen wir hier unseren Schaum drauf.
Damit wir das Bild kriegen,
was wir im Film sehen.
Bevor wir draufschlagen,
fassen wir zusammen,
was passiert ist.
Wir wissen,
dass Gallium Metalle schwächt.
Beziehungsweise auch lösen kann.
Und dass chemische Prozesse
unter erhöhter Temperatur
schneller stattfinden.
Wir nahmen deshalb 2 Komponenten,
die einen Schaum bilden.
Bei dieser Schaumbildung
entsteht genau diese Hitze,
die wir im Film brauchen,
um die Legierungsbildung zu fördern.
Natürlich alles im Kleinen,
ein bisschen verändert.
Geheimagenten
würden es wohl anders machen.
Aber Fakt ist: Mit den Komponenten
funktioniert das in echt.
Das schauen wir uns an,
indem wir ordentlich draufhauen.
Mit unbearbeitetem Aluminium
würde Folgendes passieren.
Jetzt gucken wir mal,
was das Gallium für Effekte hatte.
What?
Aber so ...
Oh mein Gott, es ist gerissen.
Ey, perfekt.
Darf ich was sagen?
Wir haben "Mission Impossible"
doppelt im echten Leben nachgemacht.
Wir haben es possible gemacht.
- Oh god, yes!
*Sie lachen.*
Geil.
Finde ich mega gut.
Das ist genau das, was wir wollten.
Es sieht exakt aus wie beim Laster.
Ja, wirklich.
Leute, das hat Spaß gemacht.
Welche Agenten-Gadgets
sollen wir noch für euch checken?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Und drückt am besten auf "Liken",
auf "Abonnieren" und auf die Glocke.
Dann verpasst ihr nichts mehr.
Ich bedanke mich bei Techtastisch,
dass wir zusammen
experimentieren konnten.
Ihr könnt auf seinen Kanal schauen,
den Link packe ich in die Info-Box.
Wenn ihr richtige Gallium-Fans
geworden seid,
packe ich euch die Gallium-Playlist
mit unten rein.
Und danke an Jan Lindner,
der uns so ein schönes Intro
eingesprochen hat.
Er hat einen Creepypasta-Podcast.
Wenn ihr mit Gruselgeschichten
einschlafen wollt,
dann schaut in die Info-Box.
Jan, hast du noch was zu sagen,
zum Abschluss der Folge?
(Jan) "Mission abgeschlossen.
Diese Aufnahme zerstört sich
in 5 Sekunden von selbst."
*Titelmusik: "Mission Impossible"*
*laute Explosion*
UT: Copyright MDR 2023